[Musik]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen den
Fachkräftemangel ich bin Larissa und ich
bekomme für den Fachkräftemangel heute
mache ich mit euch wieder
fachkrafttraining dafür müsst ihr aber
nicht ins Studio nein das mache ich mit
euch online weil ja weil weil ich ja
nichts kaputt drin bin und nett
[Musik]
ich bin hier heute in einem Bürgerbüro
einer Stadt und die heißt
Entschuldigung wie heißt die Nummer
Koblenz
nie gehört ehrlich gesagt aber auch hier
ein Problem die Menschen unter zu wenig
Fachkräften anscheinend fehlen in
unserem ganzen Land Deutschland
360.000 Menschen im öffentlichen Dienst
und deshalb brauchen wir euch hier klar
also ich muss zugeben es ist kein
richtiger Job so wie YouTube Star oder
Türsteher aber auch die sinnlosen
arbeiten muss ja jemand erledigen ist ja
so ich bin sehr stolz auf Dich oh
was ist dein Mann ja cool der sieht voll
ähnlich
[Musik]
das Problem ist überall gleich zu wenig
Fachkräfte zu viele Leute gehen in Rente
weil sie alt sind und ja sprechen bis
aus sie wollen nicht mehr arbeiten in
Stuttgart mussten sogar schon
Bürgerbüros schließen weil keine Leute
mehr da waren das ist jetzt eigentlich
nicht so schlimm weil wer will schon in
Stuttgart wohnen aber dieses Problem
wird ja bald auch ankommen in so
richtigen Städten auch hier in Koblenz
warten viele Bürger manchmal Monate auf
Ihren Termin wenn ich das Problem
wirklich verstehen will dann muss ich
das Warten mit meinen eigenen Körper
erfahren Achtung Recherche Experiment
auch
herzlich willkommen bei Larissas
Experiment
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das waren jetzt fast zwei Minuten das
war das härteste Experiment ever es war
unerträglich ich schwöre du kannst es
nicht weitergehen
sag es euch wenn du die Arbeit ist
niemand mag Dich die Menschen der
Verwaltung sie werden sehr oft von
Kunden beleidigt deshalb ziehen Sie 20%
mehr als andere Menschen in anderen Jobs
und diese Zahl ist nicht gelogen wie man
hier ja sehr deutlich erkennen kann
niemand ist da
okay sie hat sich neue Kaffee geholt
woher soll ich das wissen ein weiteres
Problem ist die Digitalisierung sie ist
in dieser Welt noch nicht angekommen
alle Verwaltungsleistungen sollten
eigentlich bis 2022 digital sein das war
letztes Jahr ich denke mal diese
Deadline schaffen sie bestimmt nicht
mehr es ist hier wie ein paralleles
Universum finde ich alles steht hier
noch auf Papier wirklich in sogenannten
Akten ich zeige euch das mal das ist für
normale Menschen voll interessant also
das hier ist die Akte und hier schaut
mal
man kann die nicht größer machen weil
die nicht digital ist das ist hier wie
300 vor Christus im Mittelalter ich
schwöre hey Frau
ist das ein Faxgerät das ist ein Locher
man lernte so viel
vielleicht will ja auch keiner den Job
machen weil man so oft mit
unfreundlichen Menschen zu tun hat den
sogenannten Kunden ich kann das wohl gut
ja es kann ja sein dass das Foto
biometrisch ist aber sie trotzdem
scheiße aus willst du das wirklich auf
deinen Perso haben überleg mal für den
Rest deines Lebens also ich würde dir
empfehlen du machst lieber noch mal ein
duckface selfie und dann machst du viel
da drauf oder besser zwei oder drei ich
beschäftige mach mal so die Hand an dein
Kind genau und jetzt mach mal so ja
genau so
ja natürlich kannst du einen
Führerschein beantragen aber ich sag nur
so die Fahrschule die Prüfung dann der
ganze Stress ich weiß nicht das lohnt
sich doch gar nicht ich kenne einen der
hat ein Cousin von dem der Freund der
Nachbar der könnte dir einfach einen
besorgen für 50 € oder so macht das
wirklich
aber es gibt natürlich Ideen wie man den
Beruf attraktiver machen kann
Homeoffice zum Beispiel ich persönlich
finde das doof weil wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass die ganzen Leute da zu
mir nach Hause kommt und dann wurde
vielleicht auch noch auf Klo
oder natürlich die vier Tage Woche das
ist eine super Idee um die Leute für den
Job zu begeistern und ganz ehrlich mit
vier Tage die Woche könnte ich mit
diesem Beruf auch vorstellen ich finde
gut von Donnerstag bis Sonntag weil dann
sind das schon zwei drei Tage dabei und
bleiben nur noch zwei Tage dann für die
Arbeit übrig und das finde ich es echt
eine gute work-live-balance ihr seht der
Fortschritt lässt sich nicht aufhalten
also mein persönliches Fazit
Verwaltungsfachangestellte ist ein Beruf
der sich wirklich lohnt wirklich weil
man verdient doch gar nicht so schlecht
und ihr habt theoretisch sogar die
Chance Beamten zu werden ja auch wenn
dein Mann bist Beamten das ist ja das
ist quasi der Jackpot finanziell und vom
Geld
merke ich habe Teilzeit was mache ich
eigentlich noch Problem
[Musik]
wenn euch auch mal wieder so langweilig
ist wie mir gerade dann guck doch die
Filme sie sind schön und die heute-show
ist sehr gut abonniert den Kanal